you mentioned time travel so
um
i mean according to einstein
any in general
what
types of travel do you think our
physical universe allows well certainly
allows
time travel to the future and i'm not
talking about the silly thing that you
and i are now going into the future
second by second second i'm talking
about really the diversion that you see
in hollywood at least in terms of its
net effect whereby
an individual
can follow an einsteinian
strategy
and
propel themselves into the future in
some sense more quickly so if i wanted
to see what's happening on planet earth
1 million years from now
einstein tells me how to get 1 million
years from now build a ship i got to
turn to guys you know who know how to
build stuff i can't do it like you build
a ship that can go out into the universe
near the speed of light
turn around and come back let's say it's
a six-month journey out a six-month
journey back and einstein tells me how
fast i need to travel how close to the
speed of light i need to go so that when
i step out of my ship
it will now be one million years into
the future on
planet earth
and this is not
a controversial statement right this is
not something where there's
differences of opinion in the scientific
community any scientist who knows
anything about what einstein taught us
agrees with what i just said it's it's
commonplace it's bread and butter
physics and so that kind of travel to
the future is absolutely allowed
by the laws of physics there are
engineering challenges they're they're
technological challenges close to the
speed of light yeah yeah and they're
they're even biological challenges right
they're g-forces that you're going to
experience you know so there's all sorts
of stuff embedded in this but those
i will call the details and those
details
notwithstanding
the universe allows this kind of travel
to the future and if i could pause real
quick
you can also at the macro level
with biology extend the human lifespan
to do a kind of
travel forward in time
if you expand how long we live yeah
that's a way to from a perspective of an
observer a conscious observer that is a
human being
you're essentially traveling forward in
time by allowing yourself to live long
enough to see the thing yes so that's in
the space of biology
uh what about traveling back in time
yeah that's the um
that is a natural next question
especially if you uh if you're doing if
you're going on one of these journeys is
it a one-way journey yeah can you can
you come back
and
the physics community doesn't speak with
a unified voice on this as yet but i
would say that the dominant perspective
is that you cannot get back
now having said that there are proposals
that serious people have written papers
on
regarding hypothetical ways in which you
could travel to the past and
we've seen some of these again hollywood
loves to take the most sexy ideas of
physics and build narratives around them
this idea of a wormhole like jody foster
and contact went through a wormhole a
deep space nine star i'm sure there are
many other examples where these ideas
that i've probably never even seen but
with wormholes there's at least a
proposal of how you could take a
wormhole tunnel through space-time
manipulate the openings of the wormhole
in such a way that the openings are no
longer synchronous they are out of sync
relative to each other which would mean
one's ahead and one's behind which means
if you go through one direction you
travel to the future if you go back you
travel to the past
now
we don't know if there are wormholes
possible according to einstein correct
they are possible according to einstein
but even einstein was very quick to say
just because my math allows for
something doesn't mean it's real and he
famously didn't even believe in black
holes yeah didn't believe in the big
bang right and yet the big the the black
hole issue has really been settled now
we have
radio telescopic photographs of the
black hole in m87 it was in newspapers
around the world just a couple of years
ago so so it's just to say that just
because it's in einstein's math
it doesn't mean it's real but yes it is
the case that wormholes are allowed by
einstein's equations and in principle
you can imagine you know putting
electric charges on the openings of the
wormhole allowing you to toe them around
in a manner that could yield this
temporal asymmetry between them maybe
you toe one of the mouths to the edge of
a black hole in principle you can do
this slowing down the passage of time
near that black hole and then when you
bring it back it will be well out of
sync with the other opening and
therefore could be a significant
temporal gap between one and the other
but people have studied this in more
detail question could you ever keep a
wormhole open assuming it does exist
could you ever travel through a wormhole
or would there be a requirement of some
kind of exotic matter to prop it open
that perhaps doesn't exist so
there are many many issues that people
have raised and i would say that the
general sentiment
is that it's unlikely
that this kind of scenario is going to
survive our deeper understanding of
physics when we finally have it but that
doesn't mean that the door is closed so
maybe it's a
a small possibility that this could one
day be right that's such an interesting
way to put it
it will not this kind of scenario will
not survive deep understanding of
physics
it's an interesting way to put it
because
it makes you wonder what kind of
scenarios
will be created by our deeper
understanding of physics
you